this morning as part of our black
history month coverage we are looking at
how racism hurts the economy and affects
all americans author and economic policy
analyst heather mcgee explores this
in her new book it's called the sum of
us what racism costs everyone
and how we can prosper together we took
a look at what this actually means
for americans wallets the wage gap
between white and black americans has
widened in the past 20 years to roughly
33 thousand dollars per household
and we all pay a price for it mckinsey
and company for example predicts that
the wealth gap will drain at least a
trillion dollars out of the u.s economy
annually over the next decade
and that translates into a loss of 2 800
or more for every american
heather mcgee is an author and economic
policy analyst who traveled across the
country
investigating the ways racism hurts more
than just people of color
at an auto factory in mississippi for
instance she found workers trying to
organize into a union to get higher
pay health coverage and a pension but
one white worker told her if black
employees were in favor
they would be against it another believe
that if you help black people succeed
you're pushing down
white people in the end mcgee says the
union vote failed
and so did the push for a better deal
for all
and heather mcgee joins us now heather
good morning to you this book is a
tremendous accomplishment and there's
one line in particular that i love you
say that
wealth is where history shows up in your
wallet
but the costs of this racism for all of
us go beyond just the money in our
wallet so i was hoping you could give us
some additional examples i love in
particular the one of the swimming pool
yeah you know i wrote this book to
figure out why it is that we sort of
can't
seem to have nice things in this country
and one of those nice things
is the public swimming pools we used to
have nearly 2
000 in america and i traveled to one of
the many towns
in the country that drained their public
swimming pool
because it was segregated and when the
civil rights movement allowed black
americans to say hey we
pay for that pool to let us swim to
instead
of integrating it they drained it of
course that meant that communities
all communities lost out and in many
ways it feels like
america has done that time and time
again that
we've had this ambivalence about sharing
our nation across lines of race and so
it's cost us all
economically how do you think american
life would look and feel differently
if our politics were not so divided by
race if people were all
voting as a different kind of economic
block
that's such a good question you know i
think about issues
like the debt for diploma system that we
currently have right a trillion and a
half dollars in student loan debt
to see what it'd be like if we voted
differently if we were in more
solidarity with one another
you just have to look back to the period
of time when government used to pay
basically full freight for people to go
to college of course that was when the
majority of the college-going population
overwhelmingly were white and we've
shifted to this student debt system
as the country has had more students of
color going to college
that's just one example of where racism
has a cost for everyone
i know heather you really you really did
your homework in terms of how you
traveled the country
it seemed like you were trying to
connect the dots one thing that stood
out to me was
white high school dropouts have a higher
average of income
household wealth than black people who
graduated from college i thought
how in the world could that possibly be
true and you talk to everyday people you
said and experts to connect the dots on
racism
that's right i mean what we don't know
so often in this country is how much
the formula that built the great
american middle class
is one that we've walked away from since
the civil rights movement
but it was full of what we now sort of
deride as free stuff
free grants to college subsidized
housing and
most of that was exclusive was whites
only
was segregated and it was when we had to
sort of
integrate the pool not just the public
swimming pool but
the pool of resources that we drained
them
and now you've got most american
families struggling to make ends meet
before the pandemic
40 percent of workers weren't making
enough to make ends meet
not everybody that does a book gets to
talk to their mom but your mom is dr
christopher she's an expert in public
health and social policy and one of the
questions that you asked in the book is
who are we as an american and who are we
to each other
i love this question because i'm very
curious about what the answer is to the
question
you know my mom is the the creator of a
framework for a process that
i think could bring this country
together it's called truth racial
healing and transformation it's
happening all over the country
i visited with folks in dallas who are
doing it and it takes stakeholders
together business leaders people in
public libraries
community leaders and says what is the
vision we want for this country
ours is the world's grandest experiment
in a multi-racial democracy
there's someone in this country with a
tie to every single community on the
globe
and when we link arms together across
race
when we lean into diversity as our
superpower i truly believe and writing
this book has made me more convinced
there is nothing our country can't do
diversity is superpower
for that reason it really is a book for
all americans heather mcgee thank you
very much for coming on to talk about it
the book is called the sum of us what
racism costs everyone and how
we can prosper together and it goes on
sale tomorrow